مستشفى كمال عدوان رغم خطوره الموقف ما
زالت قوات الاحتلال تطلق قذائفها في محيط
المستشفى كما نسمع هذه الاصوات المباشره
بجانب المستشفى الشظايا الان تتساقط على
مستشفى كمال عدوان بسبب كثافه هذه القذائف
يوجد عدد كبير من النازحين والجرحى داخل
هذا المستشفى هناك حاله من الرعب والخوف
عند المواطنين في داخل مستشفى كمال عدوان
جراء القصف المتواصل في محيط المستشفى
كمال عدوان كما نسمع هذه الاصوات بجانب
المستشفى الشظايا الان تتساقط على الاهالي
وعلى النازحين وعلى المواطنين في داخل
مستشفى كمال
عدوان ايضا طائرات الاحتلال ما زالت تطلق
النار باتجاه
المستشفى كما نسمع هذه الاصوات بجانب
المستشفى طب طبعا كما نشاهد هنا جثامين
بعض الشهداء لم يتمكن احد من دفنهم خلال
اليوم لخطوره الموقف في هذه المنطقه حتى
اللحظه ايضا هناك عدد كبير من الاصابات ما
زالت في داخل
المستشفى طبعا كما كما نشاهد هنا ساحه
المستشفى فارغه تماما بسبب تساقط الشظايا
على النازحين وعلى المواطنين في داخل هذا
المستشفى
ما زالت حتى اللحظه مدفعيه الاحتلال تطلق
قذائفها بجانب مستشفى كمال عدوان وبشكل
مباشر على المستشفى ايضا وايضا هناك اطلاق
نار من قبل طائرات كوات كابتر على مستشفى
كمال عدوان هنا الموقف صعب
جدا هنا الموقف صعب جدا كما نشاهد هنا
الاطفال والنساء اي لا مكان ولا مامن لهم
الشضن تتساقط عليهم في داخل مستشفى كمال
عدوان الوضع صعب جدا
هنا الان في قسم الاستقبال داخل مستشفى
كمال عدوان هناك عدد من الاصابات وصلت
جراء القصف المستمر في محيط مستشفى كمال
عدوان وفي مخيم جباليا وفي بيت لاهيه وفي
منطقه العلمي هناك عدد من الاصابات في
المكان كما نشاهد تكدس في المكان
هنا الوضع الصحي صعب جدا ايضا بسبب القصف
المستمر لم تتمكن الطواقم
الطبيه من التعامل مع جميع
الاصابات هناك من هو مصاب
يستشهد بسبب
نقص المعدات الطبيه والكوادر الطبيه ايضا
في المكان كما نشاهد هنا الاصابات
والش نشاهد هنا من الجانب الاخر في داخل
مستشفى كمال عدوان تكدس عدد كبير من
المواطنين النازحين الى مستشفى كمال عدوان
حاله من الرعب والخوف جراء القصف المتواصل
على مستشفى كمال عدوان وعلى محيط المستشفى
ايضا نشاهد هنا الدخان من المكان بجانب
المستشفى جراء القصف
المستمر والله احنا جينا من منطقه الشيخ
زايد دف خطوطنا واحنا جينا في امان ال
تقصد
هذا دمار وين الناس وين الام العربيه
والاسلاميه بكفي اطفالنا قتلوهم هدوا
بيوتنا اخوات استشهدوا كلهم وينهم العربيه
احنا نازحين والمفروض نقعد في المستشفى
امنين ومن ضرب القبائل في الشبايه بط
علينا والناس مصابين وفيش قادر تعالجهم
ونازحين وقاعدين في قلب المستشفى عشان
نامن حالنا احنا واطفالنا واولادنا الوضع
عنان سيء جدا من اطفال من نساء من شباب من
الظهريه ومن ارس مستمر بالقذائف على داخل
المستشف
وا الناس الج فوق بعض الناس من بنا من
صبايا من شباب من
مسنين الناس جميعا كلهم نازحون الى داخل
المستشفى كم العدوان منذ يومين لم يتوقف
القصف دقيقه واحده قصف المدفع والحزام
الناري قنابل الغاز وقنابل الفسفور
المنظومه الصحيه كلها سقطت منذ قبل الهدنه
بدايه الهدن الوضع كارثي داخل المستشفى
نحن لا نستطيع الخروج او الدخول ال
المستشفى الاطفال هنا والنساء يشعرون
بالجوع والعطش هناك مرضى للسكر وهناك مرضى
للسرطان الوضع اقل ما يوصف به الكارث نحن
الان نطالب بكل نستنجد العالم
جميعا وقف اطلاق نار بشكل كامل دون العوده
له هناك المسنون وهناك الاطفال وهناك
النساء نحن نعاني اليات هنا القصف لا
يتوقف ابدا قبل قليل
قصفوا حول مستشفى كمال عدوان والشرائع
محيط المستشفى كله والصبايا داخل المستشفى
هناك اصابات الامس عباء المستشفى كم عدوان
هناش مين ليس ي سلاحا ولا يحم شي انهم
يحملق اطفالهم اطفالهم ونحن الان اعمل معك
تسمع صوت الشبايه ينزع على بعض السكان على
بعض المواطنين بعض النازحين من بيوتهم ا
حسبي الله ونعم الوكيل وانا لله وانا اليه
راجعون وطالب من كل العالم ومن كل واحد
شريف الوط
كما شاهدتم الاحتلال يحاصر مستشفى كمال
عدوان والتي تضم الاف النازحين والجرحى
والمرضى في داخل المستشفى انس الشريف
لصالح قناه الجزيره شمال
غزه